Even if you don't understand story structure you
feel it this is the foundation of how you create
that emotional experience for the audience
or for the readers your protagonist goes
through a series of experiences that lead to
a transformation everything in the story must
keep changing point of no return is the one moment
that's external to the character which is a very
specific thing that happens once in the screenplay
the clock isn't ticking quite as fast yet think of
it as four 15 minute scripts that each one builds
on the last that's one of the things that confuses
people when they're trying to learn about the
15 beats you're writing 120 page script or it's
10 pages of sequence if you write if you're more
like 100 page script it's eight or nine pages of
sequence it's not deciding what you will write
it's providing a form and a template with which
the writer pours their story into there's not
enough scenes here there's not enough that's
happening for this to fill two hours I feel
like I've heard about that before what is this
crazy thing called the hero's journey we're
all talking about the same stuff it's really
just here's your pie you're gonna slice it into
eighths or sixteenths or whatever every writer has
a different process and a way of thinking about
stories so I think it's really good to expose
yourself as a writer to all the different models
and see okay which one helps me and that's what
a carpenter would do if he wanted to make a table
he would take a table apart and see how it was put
together that's what a mechanic would do if he
wanted to build an engine creative people might
want to resist oh no you're going to make it too
rigid actually it's freeing it's freeing if where
you're going you can go there very well if you're
lost you have a hard time making anything work out
I would look at screenplay structure as how
you tell a story and depending upon the kind
of screenplay you're writing the structure is
different in general we've all learned about
three act structure in some way shape or form
that three act structure can then be broken
down into just two acts if you're writing a half
hour multi-camera comedy it can be spread out into
four or five or six acts if you're doing a one
hour drama but your half hour single camera and
your features are usually told in three acts and
if you wanna break it down and make it as simple
as possible your first act is your setup it's
giving me all the information I need to know
of why I am here your second act is the journey
to reach the goal and then your third act
is what happened now that I reached the goal
right so it's your resolution so you have your
setup your journey and your resolution and so if
you can understand that anytime we hear a story
bedtime story dr seuss what happened last
weekend we're all listening for the setup
the journey to success or failure and
then what happened after that so to me
that's like the simplest way of talking
about what structure is for a screenplay
one of my favorite instructors that
I worked with his name is ron mita
he taught a class over in valencia and he
wrote swat and then I think he sold some
stuff he developed robots for blue sky or
something really good guy very practical
great writer very cool guy he's
amazing for pitching as well
and he had this he was the one that introduced
me to this idea of just 24 plot points
and and he said just literally just write
down 24 just 24 numbers and just put pp
plot point plot point and then break it down
into the first act and then most people say
first second and third but everybody divides it at
the midpoint plot point six is end of act one plot
point twelve is a midpoint plot point eighteen is
your low point and then plot point I think it was
21 is your climax and then after that's falling
action very simple and it's like we would we
would literally just sit there and plot out a
story in an hour and it's it's super pragmatic
so from there it really came down to trying
to understand all right if we keep dividing
everything in midpoint like pilar for example
she'll use act a 2a and 2b and it kept on begging
this question what is an act the way I look
at an act is essentially defined by strategies
so a character the the first act is a character
has a specific strategy which is their normal
daily life this is the value systems that they
that have gotten them to this point in life
so when the impetus comes in and throws their
life out of balance they find suddenly that they
have to they start to negotiate it and try and be
like well I don't want to change my life I don't
want to do anything but the second they cross that
threshold and begin to shift into a new strategy
then they've crossed into a new act so what
I've found every single time is that act
two for example you usually have a character
that's trying something new like tootsie how
did I watched that as a kid oh god it's so great
public is brilliant so you have michael dorsey
who's dressed as dorothy michaels and he's
having success and everything he's doing is
bringing more and more success and it looks like
hey this new strategy is working before that his
strategy was I'm going to be a difficult actor
until no one will work with him so he hits his
breaking point all right I'm going to dress as
a woman and commit completely to the role and
and he sees nothing but success until you hit
the midpoint when everything that he's doing
feels like it's paying off but ultimately betrays
his authenticity so it's at the midpoint where
basically you feel like you're getting everything
you want and this can com is completely subjected
to the needs of the story this is just
generally how the how the structure tends to go
but when you hit the midpoint often you're you
learn that you are as far away from your original
objective as you could be thinking that you're
just about to achieve it generally speaking and
that realization whatever that is the introduction
of a new conflict or something like that
creates a kind of a shift in strategy and usually
that strategy is very like frantic and coping and
so all the value systems that had informed that
earlier strategy of hey everything's gonna work
you hit the midpoint and it's failing and you
just come tumbling down the mountain until you
get down to the low point because all the the
first two acts are all about setup and then the
second two are all about payoff so that sec that
that third what I define as an act what is 2b
but I just call it act 3. it's easier that way is
really just a strategy of collapsing down the hill
until you get to the low point so all of
those choices are paying off but for the bad
gil calls me up and goes I just discovered this
really cool book called the hero within it's
got these six archetypes and I was looking
at some of the movies that I really like
and I noticed that the main character
moves through four of the six archetypes
like clockwork I was like really so you're saying
yeah it's like act one the main character is an
orphan of some kind either a figurative
orphan or a literal often orphan so the
main character is an orphan of some kind
in act one act two they become a wanderer
then we'll we'll tie it back to the central
question at some point but act two they become
a wanderer act three in my four act structure they
become a warrior and act four they become a martyr
it's like wow it's really interesting it can't
possibly be true but it's really interesting and
I started looking at movies and stories and going
oh my god it is true like every well-constructed
story the main character goes through these
four archetypes like clockwork and it's it
just became like this it almost became like the
it's like one of the defining cornerstones of
of of my whole understanding of story was that
like so many things kind of like fell into place
as a result of understanding those
four archetypes even to the point where
like one of the earliest kind of aha moments
I had was talking to an exec at disney
who I pitched some story I don't remember
what it was anymore I pitched him a story and
he went yeah that was okay but your story
didn't answer the four central questions
I was like okay what what might those four
central questions be and it's like who's your main
character what are they trying to accomplish who's
trying to stop them and what happens if they fail
right so so suddenly you went understanding
the archetypes suddenly start started to
shed some light on the the central question
that not central questions the the four
questions of of the film like who's your main
character it's on the orphan what's he trying
to accomplish that's wanderer right who's
trying to stop them right that's warrior
because somebody's trying to stop you you're going
to stop them back that's warrior and what happens
if they fail that's martyr so it's like suddenly
like everything started folding in on itself
that these archetypes started now relaying
relating to the four main questions of
of your story which just started relating into
the four acts of the of the structure that I had
you can now start saying oh well act one is who's
your main character and orphan now act two right
and it's just everything just started like like
lining up really really neatly as a result of that
beginning middle obstacle climax that's what
that stands for well I found this out years
ago analyzing all movies that it was equally emc
square moment for me there are four crescendos in
a movie where the heroes asked to change and asked
to learn the theme of the movie and ask to learn
how to heal all the things I talk about the big
things I talk about healing learning a theme
stopping bleeding all that there's four times
in a movie story inevitably that that happens
at a crescendo it's at 30 pages in 60 pages
in 90 pages in and about 108 pages in those
I call the beginning middle obstacle climax the
bmoc right now that's a structure that is in
every great movie practically you've ever seen
it's not in a goddard movie okay if you're
writing a french wave movie I'm sorry I won't be
able to help you that's just a french guy peeing
in an alley for two hours and that's great right I
love those movies but but in a in a hollywood film
that structure is invariably in the story and
if it's not there's usually something missing
it'll be superseded someday but that's what's
operating now now that bmoc operates in everything
ev every movie dunkirk in deadpool everything
but now in deadpool let's just take an example
in deadpool which is a great movie again
I'm big on wounds right what's our wound
in the deadpool the guy well he's wounded
because he's ugly he becomes extremely
disfigured by a chemical bath right and because
of his wound I'm ugly he can't face his girl
he doesn't feel lovable so the big crescendos the
bmoc points in that movie are is he gonna have the
the balls or or the courage to believe that his
his girl will love him even though he's ugly okay
so what he's got to learn in there to heal his
wound is I'm lovable his wound is I'm not lovable
right and and that's a wound we can all identify
with what a lot of us think we're not lovable
so he's his journey in deadpool the crescendos
of the movie are are you going to realize you're
lovable well the answer for for him is yes no
no no yes yes no no yes because after he gets
chemically doused he he's too ugly and it takes
him most of the movie to get to where he can take
his mask off that's the climax right that's the
final one takes the mask off now I use deadpool
I could use a more highfalutin movie but I want
people to understand these these this pattern of
the bmoc works in every movie now you can say
wow that's great here that's a tool ah so what
the tool will help you write your movie you
got to figure out what your theme is you got
to figure out what your character's wound
is and you have to figure out how they're
going to be healing it that's it those are the
three things so this tool works in drama and in
comedy and tv as well because why because what we
want to see in a story is a hero learning to heal
and even if he doesn't heal completely because
he doesn't in tv he's still going to go on a
journey towards healing a little bit the critical
difference between film and television is in tv
the hero doesn't heal but he heals a little bit
and then at the end he gets ripped open again
so every week he's going to heal a little bit
and then get ripped open again every week 150
times but the bmoc works at the exact same places
in the television hour than it does in a movie
there's just an extra m
because there's an extra act
so let's take a four act television structure
the bmoc it's bmmoc the oc the obstacle point
is the point when it looks like the year is going
to lose and in a movie this is right at the 90
page point let's take a movie everybody knows star
wars luke gets to the planet the last rebel planet
darth has followed him there with a homing beacon
he's got a death star he's gonna blow up the whole
damn thing there's nothing luke can do about it
there's just a little few starfighters and he's
got a death star that's it the movie's over and
then of course what happens r2d2 says hey I stole
the plans of the death star there's a little hole
you can fill a missile in if you really get close
and luke you can the only one get that missile in
that hole if you use the force not your computer
and so the obstacle point is all is lost and
the climaxes luke learns the theme of the story
luke will you use the force to rescue the princess
and save the republic he puts his computer away
all the other starfighters used it they couldn't
get the missile in he puts his computer away he's
learned he hears oh we want to say luke use
the force not the computer and he puts the
missile in the whole climax so the obstacle point
is always lost and the climax is luke you did it
in breaking bad the obstacle point is he's making
meth in the desert jesse comes back out with the
crazy eight and the other criminal they're
gonna kill them both walt's in his underwear
he has no defense he's gonna get
shot and killed but then he says
I'll teach you I'll teach you how to
cook I'll teach you how to cook my recipe
and the guy goes really yes and they go in
the rv and walter throws poison into the thing
whoosh and the climax is he kills them both
and becomes the mass murder he's gonna be
for the next 150 episodes so that's the climax so
the o and the c point and I'm not explaining this
well I'm sorry but it's in my lecture online it's
a complex little tool but it works so great it's
like a little engine that works any television
structure you want just like it did in film
let me preface it by saying this is what it's
built on I mean my underlying philosophy of all
storytelling whether you're a novelist or
screenwriter movie maker tv writer whatever
it might be is that your primary goal as a
storyteller must be to elicit emotion you must
create an emotional experience for the audience if
it's a movie or a play or for the reader if you're
a screenwriter and you have to get get it read so
you can get the movie made or if you're a novelist
or whatever so your primary goal has to be to
create emotion and this is a way to accomplish
that goal these are the this is the foundation of
how you create that emotional experience for the
audience or for the reader and so these six stages
are the six stages you're going to take your hero
through and also the audience through as we go
from the beginning of the story to the end so the
first of the six stages what constitutes the first
ten percent of the story is what I call the setup
that's simply where we introduce the hero you
create an emotional connection to that character
you show her living her everyday life then
there's a turning point the opportunity
something new happens that takes us
into the second stage that's the next 15
of the movie or the script by the way the
percentage is if novelists are watching this are a
little more fluid you don't have to stick quite as
closely but in scripts there are one or two pages
on either side of these percentages pretty pretty
consistently so the second stage the second 15 of
the movie is what I call a new situation your hero
has now been presented with some event that takes
them somewhere new it might be geographically new
or just some new circumstance where they have to
figure out what's going on then something happens
at the one quarter mark at the end of act one
that is going to move the character towards a
specific visible goal they are going to then
declare and begin pursuing a specific finish
line that they want to reach by the end of the
story my term for that is the outer motivation
for the character because it's outwardly visible
and it's their desire so it might be to stop a
serial killer it might be to win the love of the
love interest in the movie whatever now they
begin pursuing that so they go into act two and
the first half of act two is stage three that's
progress they formulate a plan and the plan seems
to work and the obstacles start getting bigger and
bigger until finally at the midpoint of that story
they're going to make a bigger commitment to
the goal up to that point they have one foot
in one foot out now they're going to reach what
I call the point of no return something's going
to happen that demands of them that they put both
feet in so they're going to devote everything they
can now to achieving the goal they can't back up
they burn their bridges behind them so to speak
so that moves them into stage four which is
complications and higher stakes because the
further into the story the character goes the more
is at stake because it the goal becomes more and
more important to them but also the harder it is
to achieve the goal the outside world is going to
start closing in the bad guy's going to discover
that the hero is after him or whatever it might be
so it gets tougher and tougher and tougher until
at the three-quarter mark right at the end of act
two the hero is going to suffer or encounter
a major setback something's going to happen
that destroys seemingly any hope of achieving
the goal the plan is out the window the worst
possible thing that could happen happens and so in
response to that the hero will do two things first
the hero is going to retreat and try and go back
to the life they were living at the beginning
and give up on the goal but that doesn't work
they're not satisfied they're not fulfilled or
they just can't give up because somebody's life
is at stake or whatever so then they make one last
all or nothing do or die final push and that's
the stage five which is the final push it's
putting everything on the line giving every ounce
of courage and energy they have until they reach
the final turning point the fifth turning point
and that's the climax that's where everything gets
resolved that's where the hero faces the villain
for the last time or the hero wins the love of
the love interest and and they decide they're
going to live happily ever after or whatever
that climax might be and then the sixth stage is
what I call the aftermath because we need to see
the new life that this hero that this character
is going to live having completed this journey
and that's pretty much it it's it's like a before
and after picture starting out in an everyday life
going through this journey to accomplish this goal
and then in the end seeing how their life has been
transformed because they took this journey I think
the parts that that cause people that make people
the most curious have to do with our analysis of
a movie of the week and that when we first wrote
the book there were a lot of movies of the week in
which we talked about the seven act structure of a
television show and the 7x structure there is a 3x
structure to stories all stories have a three-act
structure but in the renaissance for example
stories had five acts and that's because they
divided the horrible act 2 that everyone hates
I call it the serengeti plane because it's it's
the hardest part of the writing they divide it
into three acts and now there's a five act story
and it's easier to write because each act has
a beginning middle and end and each act can be
subdivided into twists and turns and scenes so
television goals goes even further and makes it
seven acts and that's because of commercials that
have to come after each act etc so people were
curious to see that but when they saw that that
the executives at the studios actually had a chart
some of them actually took the chart into
a pitch meeting and wrote down jotted down
what in the chart what the writer what the
pitch was saying about what happens in each act
and so on so here's the filled out one I'm
based on a movie that we produce and it shows
one-liners of the scenes that occur in each
act and I think people realize that this was
they didn't realize how mechanical it
was and honestly when I hear that which I
do often from writers when I'm in the old
days at least when I was teaching university
extensions all over the country I realized that
they didn't have the mentality to be writers
so let me give you a great example a woman named
millie meyer god rest her soul wonderful wonderful
lady he was a client for years came up to me at
a riverside uc riverside workshop after and she
goes I didn't want to say anything in front of
the class because I didn't want people to make
fun of me but I took my favorite book the grapes
of wrath and I outlined it and is that stupid
and I said no you're the only craftsman in the
class I mean that's what a carpenter would do
if he wanted to make a table he would take a
table apart and see how it was put together
that's what a mechanic would do if he wanted
to build an engine he'd take an engine apart
so that's exactly what you do and when I when
they see this kind of breakdown they understand
exactly how the mechanics of it work and honestly
until you get to that point you're really not
ready to be a professional writer because if you
thought that writing was a magic magic trick that
you have to pull off every time or a miracle which
I guess most writers probably would think miracle
rather than magic trick then it's impossible right
but it's not possible I mean it's not impossible
it's possible to be a writer people have been
writers for centuries they've been storytellers
and and storytellers tell stories in parts and
they know what the parts are and they do them in
a way that makes sense and so the sooner you get
down to the mechanics of how it works the better
and that's what we try to do in our books is to
show people the mechanics I'm looking through for
another there's another page in here where we
show what we call an intensity chart where you
kind of type one liners of your whole
story on it on a single piece of paper
one-liners of all the important scenes in the
story then you go between the lines and let's say
you put hyphens two hyphens for a non-dramatic
scene or a scene with relatively little drama
and like five hyphens for a scene with much
more drama and ten hyphens with maximum
drama right so now you've got a page that
has all these hyphens on it underneath the
sentences right then you draw a line across the
hyphens connecting the hyphens and then you turn
it on its side you turn the piece of paper
on its side and what you've got is something
that looks like a roller coaster and it because
it shows you the ups and downs in your stories
based on the drama the intensity
of the drama in your stories and
that is a great diagnostic tool because if you see
that there's a whole slope that in which the thing
keeps going down down down and doesn't go up for
a while or it levels off then you need to work on
that part of your story so that's what I call the
mechanical approach what I mean by mechanics like
when you when you want to outline a screenplay
or a book you just use three three by five
cards and you put on those three by five
cards the obligatory scenes in the book
and you won't fill up a whole card because
it'll just be a couple of words on each card
and what you understand when you start doing
that is that creation of a literary work
is what aristotle called an imitation of reality
it's not reality you're not re building the cider
house and and the world around the cider house
you're faking it you're making the reader believe
it's there and you do that mechanically by like I
would if I were making the movie I build a house
front that looks like this outer cider house right
but it wouldn't have a back because I'm only going
to shoot the front of it so that's what you're
doing when you're writing you're you're just
doing what's necessary to create the illusion that
you're trying to create and the audience believes
that the illusion is real because it wants to
believe that and you've given them enough evidence
to make them believe it so when you're watching
one of the old movies when they were just nobody
was dealing with production value the way we do
now it just takes a little bit to make you believe
in the story even if the acting is bad right even
if the set is laughable but you still are in the
story if the story is good if if the characters
are good and the dialogue is good and that's one
of the things that we try to instill in writers is
learn the mechanics of it because it's easier than
then you make it you're not having to recreate
a whole world you're you need to do the right
strokes to make the painting look like a person
and that's what we try to do in the treatment book
this this shows you what this is what you're
doing as you do it you you're writing little
search sentences and you're putting hyphens and
then you're drawing a line connecting them all
but then when you put it on the side you
can see the shape of your story and you
can see where it needs some attention where that
there's all these peaks here but no real valleys
so it would be much more dramatic if you dropped
some of the intensity or you added less intense
scenes in here so that the rises would be greater
etc and it could be that everything is just fine
when you do this and it looks really perfect
but most the time you'll discover that it's not
a roller coaster ride which is what you
want your reader to go on you want them to
to be screaming all the time basically and
then toward the end you see the highest peak
and then it levels down yeah it levels down
although in today's storytelling world maybe
this is not the right way to end the story
it might be better to end on a higher peak
i break it down into seven steps based similar
to to blake's system so I it's a simple way to
say it is I tell the story I get them to tell the
story or do my own work in one sentence and then
five sentences and then 15 sentences which is like
blake's 15 beats and then 40 sentences which is
basically a sentence for each scene in the movie
more or less those are the first four steps and
then the other three are screenplay draft steps
so you have get it down get it good and get it
great and and it's and it's a problem all those
those things are they're steps but they're really
almost like there's seven different ways the
audience is craving answers about your story
and most writers that aren't like fully firing
on all pistons aren't answering those questions
as deeply as they could so I'm good at doing that
in my work at least enough and then I get feedback
and I figure out how to do it even better and
when I work with other people I just make sure
that they're fully answering those questions and
then when they get to the screenplay writing part
get it down as just as quickly as you can you're
almost like formatting it I usually tell like a
write a treatment in that fourth stage after I do
like the 40 sentences for each scene I'll kind of
write that into a treatment five pages 15
pages and that was copy and paste that into the
screenplay format and then I'm just
almost reformatting it cliche this
cliche that doesn't matter bomb but just kind
of scaffolding that's that that that step five
and then step six is get it good it's not great
it's just kind of okay you got a mess of cliches
and whatever but you kind of organize it a little
bit just kind of easy breezy momentum flow and
then after a few drafts of that you're like okay
this is working you're getting good feedback again
we're in the reaction game so it's not enough if
you want to be professional that that I dislike
it's like I have to like it and then it's coming
across other people and they're saying it's great
and then when you're getting that good then you
get into that fine tuning safe get it get it great
so it's gonna get it down get it good get it great
and what I see most mistakes they make so this
is that seven step process inspired by blake's
people will get a loose idea right here like step
one and it'll jump to like step seven and it's a
fiasco and even if they finish the script you can
see it the scripts is a mess and sometimes if they
tell me what their script idea is in one sentence
it'll it'll also be a mess and I can just I can
just by seeing the one sentence I know the same
problems they have in a 100 page script starting
with the log line and premises is huge and then 15
beats is really helpful but in between those two
there's I do five sentences so act one act two a
or what blake calls fun and games your midpoint
turn and then act two b and then act three
so it's more or less the three act structure but
it's broken out into these pieces I mean this is
a turning point but like it's so important to
kind of call it out and so sometimes when I'm
even coming up with a movie idea for the in the
very beginning I'll kind of have a couple pieces
of the concept and I'll actually maybe sketch it
out the five the five sentences but it's all easy
it's kind of like well oh I know it's going to
end and I'm not quite sure about this part of that
part so I just fill in what I know and go to the
other parts and just kind of play with it and then
it just comes together if it's a good idea and
if it's easy it'll come together and if it's not
coming together at least right now I just
put it aside do something else that is easy
blake goes from concept to 15 what he calls beats
but they're not even really beats it's it's he's
what he'll have is in his 15 beats are there's
some turning points and there's sequences
and then he's got opening image closing images
which is a great bookending device and then he
calls out your b story which is your second most
significant thread and then he he talks about
the theme how it should be stated early on
and overtly and and that's it so there's a
few things that are but it's kind of a weird word
so I kind of think of his 15 story but they're
all pertinent it's like I for sure am writing a
better screenplay when I have good answers for
each of those 15 things whatever you want
to call them one of the things I added to
my process that he doesn't really talk about is
it's my step four process right it'll and most
movies will have about 40 scenes plus or minus
5 or 10 or whatever so I want to get a sense of
I'll expand those 15 beats to like the 40 scenes
and if it's 35 I don't care it's fine I just note
oh I'm a little bit short because here's
the thing the thing with structure that
throws up off a lot of people is especially people
that aren't comfortable with it yet they're like I
don't want to follow those rules it's confining
me and they use that exact tone of voice
so but what's most instructive to me and how I
also work with my mentees or students or whatever
I it's the expectations of the audience the
audience is absolutely craving beginning middle
and end they're craving your your break into act
two to happen someplace around the late 20s 25
minutes 20 blake says 27 minutes so it doesn't
have to be on that page but but if I write it
and it's five pages after that or ten pages I'm
aware of that and it's the opportunity to go
I know the audience is expecting this around 27 do
I have enough legit have I earned their trust to
go longer am I so it's totally fine to go against
their expectations but I want to do it mindfully
or it's an opportunity to go huh I'm my I'm
breaking into two at page 35 is there something
I can oh what I totally can cut this whole scene
or trim this down and then I get it closer so it's
an opportunity to very definitively look at what
the audience is expecting in a very concrete way
and go do I want to play two audience expectations
here or go against it so specifically with the 40
40 sentences for the scenes again plus or minus
5 or ten or whatever I'll do that and then I
so I so I have the bone structure of
how I can go and I often put them on
index cards and a board in my my home
office and and and then i'd like to go
from there before I go to the script to actually
write a treatment as well for two reasons one is
the those 40 cards are really good for
structural choices and thread flow and that thing
but they don't get the feeling really of
the story so that's why I go to a treatment
and then the second reason is nobody's
going to look at my 40 beats and really
get what I'm doing so if I want feedback and
I get a lot of feedback in the treatment stage
I read the treatment and then I can
five pages 10 pages whatever it takes
the screenplay that I'm working on now I actually
did three drafts of the treatment got really
good feedback between everyone then realized
that I wanted to change the protagonist from
one character to the other and then did three
more drafts of the treatment and then felt it
was good and then I'm into the screenplay so by
the time I get to the screenplay my first draft
it's not really a first draft because I've
spent so much time designing the story doing
the treatment it's it's by probably typical
fifth draft or tenth draft for other people
so I do have a few moments in time and by
moments in time I'm talking about the first scene
and the last scene so we're going to identify in
the first scene what a character wants and then
we're going to have a next moment that identify
is what I call the point of no return this is
the big event that's going to push us into the
main part of the story it's the event that makes
this movie this movie everything else on here is
internal to the character the point of no return
is the one moment that's external to the character
it's the one thing that has to happen to them
so so we're talking about groundhog day right so
the the point of no return is when he wakes up
and discovers it's the same day again right and it
should feel like it's this moment makes this movie
this movie without that scene you wouldn't have
the movie groundhog day right it's absolutely
essential so it's an important like moment like
that that's going to drive the rest of the story
it's also external you notice it
wasn't the point of no return is never
somebody decides to do something there's an
element of fate that is involved when we're
looking at the point of no return so of all the
elements it's the one thing that's external that
had to happen to him he could have not
had that happen it woken up and it was
february 3rd and then this movie wouldn't be this
movie but for whatever reason he woke up and it
was february 2nd all over again that's outside of
his control if we're going to look at the movie
tootsie sometimes people say oh the point of no
return is when he goes to audition for the part
that's a choice right so the point of no
return needs to be external to the character
so I would not identify it as he goes to
audition what and what you want to identify
is the moment outside of his control so the
part where everything really changes is when
so he could have blown that audition and he almost
blows that audition he comes very close to blowing
it but the female producer likes him right and
at one point she says I like him I like her we're
gonna hire and she leans over and says you've got
the part I'm sending the contract to your agent
that's the point of no return that because that
moment's outside of his control right that had
nothing to do with his choice he could have
blown that audition he almost did blow that
audition but that's the moment boom now we're
in the movie known as tootsie one another thing
I like to think of a great example of this is the
differences but going from act one and act two is
the wizard of oz wizard of oz act one it's a black
and white point of no return is she thinks that a
tornado has lifted her house up and dumped her
in the land of oz and boom we're in technicolor
we want that feeling when we enter
iraq too we're in a whole new world
we ain't in kansas anymore right so it's
a whole new world that there's facing it's
one thing michael dorsey decides to audition
one day as a woman it's another thing he's
got to fool everybody 24 7 into thinking he's a
woman that's the main story or in groundhog day
he's now trapped in a cycle where every day is
groundhog day that's the main part of the story
so there are two kinds of stories I talk about
in the book comedy and tragedy and these are
not these definitions don't come from don't blame
me if you don't like them they're from aristotle
these are the original academic definitions of
comedy and tragedy so when I say comedy I'm not
talking about a haha comedy I'm talking about an
aristotelian comedy and so an aristotelian comedy
according to aristotle by definition is where
we have a protagonist who overcomes a flaw so
flaw is gonna be the next element I'm gonna talk
about and that they're they're gonna go through
change and then eventually they're gonna have a
happy ending structurally we also have tragedies
a tragedy is going to be the opposite so we have
the same setup we have a character want something
they get it in a point of no return but instead of
going down down down and then coming up and having
a happy ending we're going to go in the opposite
direction they're going to go up up up before they
come down and have their sad ending 95 percent
of stories are going to be comedies by the way
yeah at least 95 the next important thing to talk
about when I talk about the point of no return
in the point of no no return the
character gets something they want
they also get something they don't want and that's
going to be what I call the catch so you get what
you want but with the catch so michael dorsey gets
a part but he's gonna have to dress up as a woman
in groundhog day phil connors only has to spend
24 hours in punxsutawney that was his want but
the catch is it's actually going to be the same
24 hours done over and over again so the catch
is attached so it's a problem we can't just give
our character what they want because that deflates
conflict so you're giving them something that
they want along with something they don't want and
the catch is also could be said to be the perfect
test of their flaw so the flaw in phil connor's
flaw is that he's self-centric this is the that
the catch being that he's gonna stuck spending the
same same day over and over again is the perfect
test if someone spla is that they're self-centered
in a comedy it's going to end in the happy ending
but they're going to go down down down down
before because you got to hit rock bottom before
you can make a change so keep in mind in your
typical haha comedy and your typical haha comedy
is an aristotelian comedy it's down down down down
we're laughing as bad things are happening
to the protagonists they are not laughing
they are not having a good time in act two of a
comedy so they're gonna go down down down until
they're gonna hit rock bottom what I call their
crisis the crisis has two requirements one is
it's their absolute lowest place and then it is
the other requirement is that the opposite of
the want actually groundhog dick has a really
interesting one in that he's actually finally
spent after being stuck there he finally
tells the truth to rita the love interest
about what's going on and they actually
have kind of a wonderful day together
but it ends in this very bittersweet
moment where they're falling asleep
and he's says and the terrible worst part is
tomorrow you're going to think I'm a jerk again
and what is wonderful about it is this wonderful
irony and that's what we're setting up with the
crisis being the opposite this irony he
only wanted to spend 24 hours in pakistani
now he wishes the day could last forever
because tomorrow she'll think he's a jerk again
so we're sending this delicious irony there then
the next thing we're going to identify in the
nutshell is we're now entering the act three the
beginning of act three is the climax of your movie
and the operative word that we're gonna use
though is the climatic choice at the heart
of a true climax your protagonist is making a
difficult decision so in groundhog day his choice
is to start stop to stop fighting it to
accept that he's there and start trying to
live every day for the fullest and so he becomes
a really good person he starts doing nice things
and saving the day and doing thinking of others
because what's the point in living and trying to
have short-term gratitude he's got to find a
different experiment with a different way of
living so he actually starts becoming this town
hero of this person who's the known as this good
guy because he's got nothing better to do and
then finally break some free of the the curse
and in the final step the final step is
the very last structural element time wise
the very last scene of the movie and now
the character's gonna come full circle so
if his flaw was that he was self-centered he's
come full circle towards opposite strength that he
now is selfless and right because he's been
doing these things for everybody in the town of
wakes up that final pakistan and he's actually
it's become february 3rd he's free of the curse
and he actually wants to stay so those are the
eight structural elements and so like I said it's
not just moments in time this is not a beat sheet
method they are what's important is the glue it's
the the structure that holds these pieces apart
it's the connection between these parts these are
not isolated moments in time we can see right on
the piece of paper what's working and what's not
and if it's not working how to adjust it by
seeing that it fits what what do we need to change
in order to meet the requirements
in order to tell a story effectively
it originates in hollywood history by the accident
of of the one real film 35 millimeter film that
became standardized by the first decade of the
20th century the first movies by that by that
time let's say that by 1910 there are single
real experiences there are 10 minutes long and
for various reasons in the teens hollywood split
in two directions from the single reel film
to what we call full-length features multi-reel
films hour and a half two hours three hours
and in the other direction to the serial which
is a real or two installments series and the uh
reason you have the origin of sequences is that in
the u.s the distribution system was so rigorously
one real a week or two wheels a week that when
they started to generate full-length feature
films they were still distributed a couple of
reels a week so if you look at manuals of the
time screenwriting manuals there are about 60
titles that came out in the 19 teens on how to
write a photo play because the market was kind of
wide open and people wanted to write these things
you'll get instructions about making sure
that each reel has a climax to it so that
the audience will be interested in seeing the next
reel and then they'll see the next one after that
so it was almost like a limited series a feature
film by the late teens you're seeing them all the
distribution system is changing and you're seeing
in theaters what we would normally experience
as a full-length feature but the the idea of
writing by the real survived into the 20s and 30s
and you can see the see the evidence of
it in the way the continuity scripts are
marked they're often marked by sequence
letter sequence a b c d and that is
where what we call sequences come the nomenclature
comes from what frank danielle discovered in
teaching in the 80s he discussed the three act
structure in terms of setting up a situation
developing it and then paying it off but he
found that the students struggled with the middle
part of the script because it's intimidating
how do you fill up 60 pages in the middle and
usually 30 pages to set it up 60 pages in the
middle and 30 pages in the third act so he revived
this idea of sequences he said well don't think of
it in terms of one act of 60 pages think of it as
four 15 minute scripts that each one builds on
the last and so thus the the sequence approach is
born you're not going to try to tackle a whole 120
pages just figure out these 15 minutes the first
one first 15 minutes and then the next 15 minutes
then that's going to really do some kind of major
problem for a character so then they're going to
try to explore the next for the next 15 minutes
and the the effect is actually very liberating
because you wind up not worrying about how you're
going to fill up these pages but more about how
you're going to trim down because now you've got
all this material but it also helps you explore
a premise really fully you have a character
let's just take a classic dramatic instruction a
character wants something and there's obstacles
okay at the end of the first act they we know
what they want we know what the obstacles are
going to be well what is the character going
to character doesn't know what the movie's
about character just thinks oh this is this
is easy I can solve this so they try something
and that's in your conceptualization of the story
the character tries the easiest thing that they
can try and then the filmmaker the screenwriter
comes up with an obstacle why that doesn't work
and that's maybe 10 15 minutes all right so now
they got to try something else what's that going
to be and you can develop it and each sequence
has its own integrity ideally the the paradigm is
that each sequence is going to have three acts
also it's going to have some kind of setup you
don't have to do as much setup because we know
the characters but you're going to have to
introduce new circumstances they're going to try
to get something and then it's going to end with
some kind of resolution usually negative because
it's positive maybe the movie's over but it leads
to the next sequence and the next one and so you
wind up with actually a kind of a nested structure
because the scenes dramatic scenes have the same
3x that's why I tend to like three acts you can
depends on how you define it but if you understand
it as working with tension which tension is just
putting something in the audience's mind hope and
fear character wants something are they going to
get it or not that's what I'm wondering about and
if I care about the character then I'm going to
stay tuned because I want to see the answer to
that so it's you don't need more than three acts
for that you just need to set that up and then
you need to develop it and then you get the answer
so each act the act set up the whole thing then
each sequence has its own okay character wants
something and there's problems and then each
scene has a character that wants something and
there's obstacles so it's like this iterative
structure that keeps the audience involved
because we're constantly wondering about what
how it's going to come out for the character
and one thing that we also we cover in the book on
the science of screenwriting is this this process
of connection to a main character and what the
theories are about why we have that and it's
certainly important if you come into a if you're
in a park and you come up on a tennis game and
two people are really battling each other it may
be interesting but it's not going to be dramatic
to you as you don't know them but if if you do
know one if you love one of them and that they
just mortgaged their house and put everything on
this game and then the other person is a hustler
then every oh my god you've got something it's
transformational but you have to make that
connection emotionally and so so to get back about
the sequence structure you have mini versions of
the three acts in sequences and then in the scenes
and that is the suspense the tension that keeps
us interested and we also we have a chapter on the
contrast in the film and that plays also into this
approach which is that in order to maintain
audience attention the stimulus has to be
changed frequently otherwise you you zone out you
you you'll lose connection you you'll think about
other things and you need to reset the audience's
brain periodically and filmmakers do it you can
see evidence of it and changing light and dark
loud and soft fast and slow but you also see it
in tension and release tension maintained for too
long gets tedious but if you release it and give
us a chance to reset then you can go on and build
it up again and again and again until you reach
the culmination of the picture and then finally
you try to release it entirely and then people get
people to say yeah I want to see that movie again
I'm going to tell my friends I want to see it
but she basically says there are 11 steps in a
feature film the first step is the character's
overall want and why so you establish through
action what they want and why they want it and
then the character logically goes for it so they
take action to try to get that thing that they
want but the character is somehow denied okay they
they that's not gonna work they can't they can't
get it that way but the character gets a second
opportunity to achieve their overall want but
there's danger around that second
opportunity like it's kind of a shady way
maybe it's not on the up and up but there's
some danger around it either emotionally
or physically okay but they want it so
badly at the end of act one they go for it
they decide to go for it again these these
forms are the same like they're just different
language around the same turning points and
stuff but at the end of act one the character
decides to go for it and now we're in act two
right and so all goes well they're going for it
look they're getting what they want oh my
god but something happens in the middle of
the script and one thing I would love to share
with your viewers is this idea of the midpoint
sometimes the midpoint people think of it as
like something happens out of the blue that
that causes everything to fall apart or it's like
a false victory and then they have to deal with
its false or whatever but I always think the best
midpoints are a moment where the character just
like everything's going okay they're getting what
they want but then they get to that cave and it's
like they're in that cave and their fear is around
them and they make a decision out of fear that
causes everything to fall apart for them they go
back to their old pattern and that actively gives
them like they drive that midpoint and and causes
everything to fall apart which in jules um 11 step
structure is called all falls apart right so all
falls apart looks like they're going to fail and
then at the end of act two there's a crisis where
they again have to make a decision or a commitment
do they go for a new strategy do they give up
what do they do usually they decide to try again
and that decision or that crisis decision drives
them into act three and then we have this climax
where it's the final attempt to get what they
want and again usually we have a transformation
right they do something they never could have
done back in act one they get what they want
and then the last phase she calls truth the truth
comes out to make things right and this is where
that the character discovers something new about
her world she has some new insight about herself
and that usually has the power to heal whatever
was broken back at the beginning of the story
and so what I love about this this story
model is that it's really goal driven
it's like they want something they
decide to go for it they get blocked
they get a second opportunity I'm afraid I want
it so much I'm going to go for it it's just it
allows you to really find that goal for your
character and let them pursue that in the story
what I'll do is I'll start with the
premise line I'll write out a premise line
basically for me like the foundation of the script
couple of sentences take take from start to finish
and then I'll expand that into I know maybe two
three four pages there's a write it in sections
so I'll divide it into into three basically if
it's a movie three movie acts but more in quarters
so it's like the equivalent of quarter quarter
quarter quarter which takes me through the four
quarters or the three acts of the of the of
the movie so it it it's I can keep it because
one of the things that happens when you start
writing it for me and when I start writing out
and that writing outline in prose form is that
if you don't if you don't for me if I don't kind
of stop writing at a certain point you end up
with let's say your outline is for pay you're
writing it just outlined four pages the first two
pages may really only be the first quarter of your
script because you you end up writing so much
and then then you have to really then ultimately
you end up with kind of disproportionate
disproportionate acts so basically I'm just
trying to to write it as tightly as I can and I'll
write it long and then I'll then I'll edit it but
in the end I want to end up with kind of four
relatively close descriptions of each quarter
okay so let's say that's that ends up being three
four pages whatever then if it's on if it's an
assignment then I'll then I'll give it to the
executive or whatever I'll get notes on it rework
it and then if it's not for me I'll do the same
thing for myself and then what I do is I divide
the and this was a really I have to credit
writer's boot camp for this because they
really this was kind of the way they taught me
how to do it and how I always do it now and I
taught other people and I think it's pretty I
mean it's one of those things that just like
I don't think it's an uncommon way to do
it but it kind of boils it down to I think
a really effective way of doing it is that
you divide I divide it up into 12 sequences
three sequences in the first act six in the second
act and three in the third act of equal weight so
basically if you're writing 120 page script or
it's 10 pages of sequence if you write if you're
more like 100 page script it's eight or nine
pages of sequence and I beat out the list of
scenes so I'll take I turn I create a sequence
sentence so this is sequence one two and three
so out of that sequence sentence that I write
right out pull from the outline the longer outline
I then write a list of the scenes that will
comprise that that that that sequence so I'll put
like the scenes in a row and then I'll figure out
how many pages that scene will approximately be
so that I can add it up add up each sequence and
say at the end those six scenes will equal eight
and a half pages or something and it's an estimate
it may sometimes I'm very off but it's an estimate
and this is just my kind of organized way of doing
it and and how I don't get lost in the process
and how I really kind of stay on track this is
just mine everybody has their way of doing it
and so I do that so ultimately you end up with
basically 12 series of of single of scene lists
so and which should ultimately when you add it all
up should equal whatever your page desired page
count is 100 105 pages 120 pages an estimate and
then I take that I put that onto my final draft
that list onto my final draft and
I create a slug line over each one
interior living room night exterior
baseball field date whatever and and
so I have the line and then I the the what the
what the scene is about and then I have the slug
line so basically what I end up with is a whole
written script except without dialogue essentially
and then you go in and just you craft it and to
me it's just it's a very step-by-step process
so it's like an accordion you're constantly
expanding that accordion until you have the
whole script written so it that that that that
works for me but everybody does it differently
distilled it down to writing a premise or a log
line for the for the the overall idea of what the
story would be and that that premise or log line
has the is is elastic in itself meaning that it
it can evolve it can change over time you can
always return to it and augment it in some way
as you are going through the writing process and
then for each of the 12 beats of my screenplay
so basically when I say 12 beats is if
a screenplay is technically 120 pages
there's a beat for every 10 pages all right
and then you're thinking of the story and
we're talking the story now as an ekg all right
so what I mean by an ekg and you can also apply
this to christopher vogler's ideas on the the
hero's journey as well the ekg is like you are
you're lifting off with your inciting incident
the inciting incident technically should occur
anywhere from like the five page two to like well
in the old days it was like five page the fir
to thirty page but like it's it's really just five
pages now you really don't go farther than that
and then and then what you do is you
you plateau off as you get towards the
towards the middle of the ekg so that's like
page 60 and that means basically that your
characters or your protagonist is on his way
to towards his journey and so that's beat six
and then on on beat nine you are you are
you are coming all the way down on your ekg
you're spiking downward because they are facing
all their adversity and all of their obstacles
that they must overcome that they may never they
may never recover from and then if they do recover
and they do succeed and they win in the end then
that ekg comes all the way back up at 12. if they
don't if they don't win then that ekg comes all
the way up at 11 and then goes sharply down at 12.
so that is that is basically that 12 point beat
outline now with the 12 point beat outline each
one of those beats 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 has
its own premise so every 10 pages or approximately
10 pages because you don't have to adhere here
strictly to 10 pages because maybe you have a
shorter script has its own log line so you go this
is when such and such happens such and such occurs
cause and effect it's a cause and effect statement
that is something that is that has a whole chapter
in la la segres the the the art of of dramatic
writing is the cause and effect statement that
goes all the way back that that can apply all the
way back to the greeks and he takes it there so
so you you do that for each one of those beats
and then from each one of those log
lines you use those as a basis to
to work on to script those 10 pages or roughly
those 10 pages and then if you adhere to that
you'll you'll probably get yourself a a first
draft it may not be much of a first draft
but it'll be something that you can you can
rewrite and that you can work on a story map is
a structural template that's followed by most
commercial films and it breaks a story a film
narrative into four acts act 1 act 2a act 2b and
act 3 and it contains 4 major story engines that
drive each one of the individual acts and 8 to 12
major signpost plot beats it's not deciding what
you will write it's providing a form and a
template with which the writer pours their story
into so a writer still makes their own unique
creative decisions but they may want to think
about what page ranges those decisions fall in
and the kind of basic beats that would inform the
storytelling the inciting incident should probably
be between eight eight to page eight to twelve
but we also want something that I call the strong
movement forward the next major beat to be in
the page 18 to 20 range sometimes that doesn't
happen until 28 and then the true end of act 1
which should be around page 30 is in the beginner
script not happening until page 38 and that really
makes the reader anxious and it slows down the
pace of the story and the structure so it's not
hitting the proper page ranges again this isn't
deciding what you should write but it's deciding
basically what page ranges the major beats should
be how you should tell the story to some extent
okay kind of that outer frame of the story with
which you're pouring your unique decisions into
but as far as mistakes there's a a major signpost
beat falling too early too late or just not being
there for example there's a beat that I call the
assumption of power or declaration of war beat
and this should happen around page 75 and you
can see it in movies it happens around minute 75
if that's not there if there's not that moment
where this character really feels their true power
and acts in a way that makes them rise to
the occasion in kind of a a declaration of
war or an attack and a declaration of intent
and something that taps their inner strength
if that's not happening in that page range I don't
think the story is necessarily moving as it should
so a classic example would be in the karate kid
the show me paint house moment show me paint the
fence show me sand the floor and it's that
moment at which daniel larusso realizes he's
been learning karate all along even though mr
miyagi has been making him do all his chores
so he asks him to show him the the
positions that he's put his hands
as he's been doing these chores and it turns
out he's been learning karate this whole time
so he really daniel really realizes his
true power realizes he can do karate
and he's doing it already you want every scene to
advance the story to explore the controlling theme
or reveal crucial character okay it has to advance
the story so definitely that first one it has to
do in some way and then ideally it will also be
on theme that major theme that central theme that
this particular story is exploring and then third
does it reveal some crucial character something
that we haven't seen before about this particular
character I think structure is very important in
hitting those page points is important for no
other reason because every reader in hollywood
has internalized that structure but I mean the
real proof in the pudding is that when you read
proscripts by produced writers by the top writers
in hollywood who are making the top money they use
this structure so there has to be something about
it that is the reason why the first act of a movie
is around 30 minutes I mean there's something
there there's some reason why that works
blake came up with this idea of the 15 beats
that make up any story he put them on a beat
sheet it's become famous now for it's a great
tool for people who are developing a story idea
I think or trying to learn about story structure
so the one I will say the one thing that I think
people who are introduced to the beat sheet
maybe overlook and then have to learn later
so this is a shortcut is that some of the beats
are turning points and then some of the beats
are sections of the story so I'll go over them
but it's useful to note that because I think
that's one of the things that confuses people
when they're trying to learn about the 15 beats
okay so the opening image is the first image of
your screenplay or of your movie it sets the tone
kind of establishes when and where we
are in the world right so the world of
your story the next beat that shows up
on the beat sheet is the theme stated
and blake wrote in save the cat I think that theme
stated shows up on page five of your screenplay
it's the theme is usually that like guiding
principle or the the big idea of the story
what it's really about kind of behind the
plot and behind the characters right and
he like to say that it was stated somewhere in
the story or on page five of your screenplay
it was stated outright usually in a line of
dialogue by one of the characters the next beat
on the on the beat sheet is the setup and that's
one of those beats to pay attention to because the
setup is actually a section of the screen play
right so it's not just one page or one scene
it's a whole section I think he notes that it
the setup is like page one to page 12 or so
and so that's introducing us to the main character
and their ordinary world or their normal world
where they are in their life right now before the
story gets started right and one of the things he
wrote about in save the cat was that you can kind
of use the idea of at home at work and at play to
introduce your protagonist so seeing them in
these different aspects of their their normal
world gives us a sense of who they are the next
beat on the beat sheet is the catalyst and that
is a beat that should be more of a turning point
like one scene or one moment in your screenplay
the catalyst is also something that other people
refer to as the inciting incident it's really the
event that kicks the story into motion sometimes
you can think of it as the why now of the story
it's this event throws your protagonist world into
disarray or forces them into action by creating
some problem or opportunity for them that they
have to take advantage of that they have to deal
with right and that's how it starts the story
into motion the next beat is the debate section
and again it's it's a section of the screenplay
so this isn't just one scene I keep emphasizing
that because I've seen writers get confused and
when they're trying to outline their stories they
get to like the debate section and they they put
in one scene and then when they go to write the
screenplay they don't have enough story to fill
out the pages right so the debate section is where
is that section in between the catalyst or the
inciting incident kicking the story into motion
and your protagonist deciding what to do about it
so there's that debate section in between there
where we really try to close all of the obvious
doors for your protagonist and funnel them toward
this main thing that they're going to
do over the course of the story right
I also like to look at the debate section as
getting the audience on board so you kind of
tell us what's at stake for the protagonist why
they have to do this thing because usually the
thing that they're going to do in act 2 is this
big audacious crazy scary dangerous thing right so
the debate section used that to get the audience
on board and show us why do they need to do this
thing why is it so important what happens
if they don't do it help us understand what
the potential consequences are so that we have
that tension of like wanting them to do it but
being a little bit worried about them right before
they go into act two so the next beat is the
break into act two so at the end of the debate
section after you've gone through all of that
gotten the audience on board shown us why the
character has to do this thing the break and
act 2 is the turn in your plot where you send the
protagonist into act 2 on to that main adventure
pursuing that story goal engaging in the
main conflict however you want to look at
it that's where that's what the break into
act 2 does the next section is the b story
the next beat is the is the b story so blake
like to say that after that main or that after
that major plot point of the break into act
2 it was a good time to give your protagonist
and your audience a little bit of a breather
and introduce a subplot he talked about the b
story being the relationship or the subplot where
your character could discuss learning the theme
so a lot of times it'll be it might be a romance
or it might be a friendship or something but it's
giving your character an opportunity
to talk about what he's learning
talk about what he's going through
and what he's learning from it
the next beat on the beat sheet is fun and games
and again this is a section of the story so the
fun and games is actually on the beat sheet it's
all of the first half of act two right so it's
it's basically everything after the break into two
up until the midpoint which we'll get to in a sec
but so the fun and games blake wrote that it was
the is where we see the promise of the premise so
whatever the concept is of your story the thing
that's hooky and intriguing about this story
that's where we see it come to fruition is in the
fun and games so I think his famous examples are
liar liar it's where we see jim carrey
getting used to not being able to tell a lie
or in legally blonde it's where we see elle
getting acclimated to harvard law and she's
very much a fish out of water so that's fun and
game stuff you can also think of it as trailer
moments right those those very entertaining
and very like on-concept moments or scenes
that you would probably cut into a trailer to show
somebody what's so entertaining about your movie
the next beat is the midpoint so that's the middle
of your story the midpoint is a is a more of a
moment or a scene instead of a section so again
just making that distinction but the midpoint can
be a few scenes in a row right it's not really
a section of your screenplay but it can be a
sequence because usually it's a big set piece
or like an action sequence or something that
is a little bit bigger than other scenes right and
really the function of the midpoint is to increase
the opposition and or raise the stakes of your
story so basically what it comes down to is the
midpoint is increasing the tension in your story
to give it more momentum to get through the second
half right so sometimes it turns the story in an
entirely new direction but doesn't always have to
in any case what it does is it it increases that
that tension feeling so that it's like winding up
a toy and letting it go so it gives us that extra
momentum and energy to get through the second
half of the story then after the midpoint the next
beat on the beat sheet is the bad guys close in so
blake like to say that this is where things really
start going wrong for your protagonist right so
you can have both external and internal bad guys
so it can be plot stuff is going wrong the literal
bad guys can be closing in getting closer gaining
on your protagonist but it can also be emotional
stuff they're really struggling with what they're
doing they feel like they can't succeed and maybe
they're having a crisis of faith or of confidence
and then you can also have conflict within
the protagonist team so that's also causing
things to fall apart right and basically the
bad guys close in section is leading us downhill
towards the next couple of beats which are the all
is lost and dark night of the soul beats and these
are separate beats on the beat sheet but I like to
talk about them together because they really are
complementary and they work together to kind of
create that low point at the end of act two so I
like to think of them as one is more external or
plot focused and one is more internal or character
focused the all is lost is usually what I think of
as the plot focused one right where it's it looks
like the character the protagonist is not going to
succeed it you might think of it as he's as far
away from his goal as he'll ever be or he feels
like he's failing he feels like there's no hope he
doesn't know how he's going to keep going on and
try to get that goal and then the dark knight
of the soul is the emotional reaction to that
other things that can happen at the all
is lost can be like the death of a mentor
I think this is where blake wrote that there's
like that whiff of death right so it can be
the loss or death of a mentor or of a friend or
of a support system it can be a major setback like
being exposed to the bad guys so now they know who
who they're up against or it can be like losing an
advantage but you want it to be pretty big because
we're talking about kind of the big turning points
of the story and then the dark night of the soul
is the emotional reaction to that right so it's
now that this big setback has happened or it looks
like I'm not going to be able to achieve my goal
the protagonist sitting in that for a moment
and wondering what do I do from here and a lot
of times that's where they have kind of a glimmer
of I finally understand the lesson of the theme I
finally understand what I should be learning from
this experience they they're not always ready to
embrace that lesson at that point yet right
but they're starting to understand like
oh this is what all of this has been trying to
teach me and then after that the next beat is
the break into act three so that's the major
turning point where we go from act two to act
three and basically it's the beginning of the
resolution section of the story right so that
turn you usually want it to feel like it's pushing
us in a new direction that is toward however
the story is going to resolve right so your
character your protagonist might have a new plan
so after that dark night of the soul moment they
might have a moment of inspiration where they're
like oh okay now I know what I what I need to
do right now I know how to defeat this bad guy
and so the break into three is where they begin
that that final push to resolve that story right
that main conflict or however you want to think
about that that story so the next beat on the beat
sheet after the break into act 3 is the finale
and this is the section that most people forget
is a section of the story instead of one scene
right so your finale or the way blake wrote
about the finale is that the finale was all of act
three so it's what you would call the resolution
right or he called it the finale so this is where
we see that new plan that your protagonist has
play out or we see them execute that that final
push toward trying to resolve the main conflict
so finale all of act three I think that is that
is that beat 14 and then there's 15 is the final
image okay so the last beat on the beat sheet
is the final image so that's after the finale
has played out we've seen how the main conflict
has resolved we've seen if the protagonist has
achieved his goal if they've succeeded or failed
how the out how the story ends basically like
what is the final outcome and then we have the
very last beat which is the final image which is
that you might think of it as like almost the
aftermath of the of the finale it's now that the
story is over give us one kind of final scene or
image or moment to kind of send the audience out
feeling how you want them to feel knowing
maybe what the character is going to do next or
if you need to recalibrate the the
emotion at the end of your story maybe
the maybe the the end of the finale was a big
action sequence and you want to leave us feeling
like knowing that your protagonist was okay and
he won and he's safe and he's rested and not
injured anymore or something like that the
final image can can do that blake also like
to write that it was the final image is like
a bookend for the opening image right so
I think some people look at it as you want the
the change or the contrast between the opening
image and the final image to be big enough to
show that there was a transformation in that
in that story right so we went from point a to
point z and there's a big enough contrast there
that we can see this story covered some ground
and had some consequence to it if that makes sense
the first speeches I ever wrote for were for tedx
orange coast I wrote eight of them and I was like
I don't know what I'm doing I know how to tell
a story but I didn't really know how do you get
the person's life from point a to point b to the
end right and so I would get halfway through the
script and by the way I had to turn around
a lot of the scripts in two to three weeks
eight of them wow so I didn't have much time
and I was working seven days a week and like
I better figure this out oh my goodness right
and so the rules were I was anti-rule really and
then one day I was working on a on a speech for
this ted talk one of them and I wanted to do this
woman justice I just adored her her name's amy
purdy and she and I were collaborating together
and I just thought I've got to do this justice
what how do I tell a story we were in there we
were doing stuff but I it just wasn't hitting
the mark and so I said okay google let's look
at my magic eight ball let me just shake it and
see what comes back and I just typed in story arc
and all of a sudden I clicked on images and
I saw something called the hero's journey
and I was like what I feel like I've
heard about that before what is this
crazy thing called the heroes journey and I
looked at the visual it's a beautiful visual
somebody taking their time to really show me
all the steps and I was like wait this is how
I this is how this works I can do this this
is exactly what I need amy had eight minutes
ted talks are often 18 minutes but she only
had eight minutes that's what they gave her
and some of my other speakers had 12 minutes
and which four minutes is a huge difference
let me tell you eight is tight and so I was like I
can do this I can cross a threshold with her story
this is wonderful and we did it and her talk
went viral and so this was back in 2011 and it
was affirmation for me and I was like I don't know
these hollywood people this way but I love them
and so then I started following that for certain
people I started using the hero's journey
and because there are there are emotional
beats in there and I noticed that my speeches
were following those beats I would just look
over i'd be like is this going the way it is
I would find it I would just mirror
them and they could almost cross map and
what was beautiful about that is that
the the people I tend to work with the
speakers I tend to work with and especially
now now that I've been doing this a long time
I'm really I really want beauty out in the world
and I want my speakers to disseminate that that
beauty which they already have in them right and
the hero's journey really does that because the
audience doesn't hear the speaker they hear what
the speaker has been through but they only think
about themselves and what they've been through
in relation to what that speaker has been through
so speakers will be like I don't know if I
could say that and I'm like it's not about you
the audience is gonna say oh my god I went through
that too or my mother went through that or someone
I knew or and they they start to they hear your
story but in relationship to themselves and so
that that hero's journey has been incredibly
important in in in the storytelling process
the first act has to deliver the dramatic
question ideally there is a protagonist
who has a very clear objective ideally there
are stakes so there are consequences if that
protagonist doesn't succeed and the higher
those stakes the more dramatic the story
ideally there is a scene and there's a whole
book save the cat that is kind of based on that
ideally you have given the audience a reason to
side with that protagonist which a lot of movies
and scripts leave out completely which is
amazing to me because it's one of the main
ingredients why would I as an audience care if
that character sees his father before he dies
there must be something that shows me a humanity
inside of that character it can be a bad bad
mafia serial killer whatever guy but something
that I can relate to where we share our humanity
in that moment so that he becomes the vehicle
for me to discover things about myself in the
end I think that's the secret that every audience
it's a very that's a very selfish process I think
every audience really comes to the theater to
learn something about themselves and not about
oklahoma or space or whatever but about their
emotions in that moment but that only works
if you can create a connection between
the protagonist and the audience earlier
so that would probably be the formula looking
for is there a connection is there a clear want
which leads to the dramatic question which is will
this protagonist successfully save the love of his
life whatever whatever and then you go into the
second act where there are where you have to look
at the conflicts is there enough is is what he
the steps he is doing are they escalating in a
way that at the same time is believable but also
doesn't need too much patience because in real
life he would probably first phone his grandmother
and then he would go we don't want to sit through
all that we want the condensed version we want the
fake version but we want it to feel emotionally
real which is a hard thing to achieve but
it's something that you can very clearly track
throughout a second act I think and the first half
of the second act normally traditionally is called
like the fun and games part which is where most
the sea of the scenes that you see in a trailer
are in the first half of the second act where the
promise of the movie the reason why people came
is to see those scenes it's like oh there's a
a man that talks to his snake mel gibson with
this beaver and jody foster's movie that would be
the first half of the second act where we kind of
have a little bit of time the clock isn't ticking
quite as fast yet and then most of the time the
mid point halfway through the story is a
more fundamental twist to the whole story
it turns out the beaver is real or has whatever
whatever can actually talk something that changes
our whole look on the story and the direction
of the story which I think is super important
because otherwise a second act gets very long like
if it's only a one directional thing which exists
of course and is exists successfully but it's very
hard to execute to keep the audience's attention
without something that in the middle kind of
breaks the movie up and gives it a whole different
direction and a lot of time like in a spy movie it
would be our protagonist finds out that the agency
he's working for is actually the the bad guys so
suddenly it's or in mad max it's when they've been
driving into that one direction and now they've
achieved whatever they need to achieve and now
they're literally turning around coming back that
would be kind of the midpoint then the stakes have
to be raised in the second half of the second
act and lead to the major confrontation then if
you go by the heroes journey which I believe in
a lot joseph campbell and all that kind of stuff
there is the major confrontation it looks like
the hero is going to die he metaphorically dies
sheds his old ego learned something about himself
that he didn't know before there's most of the
time painful and that enables him because he
doesn't break in that moment he almost breaks
you get him to the breaking point and you can see
that in almost every movie that that is being done
because we need to really break a character to see
what he's made of right if you never challenge a
character you don't know what he really has inside
of so you almost break him and in that process
of staring death in the face metaphorically
or obviously in a romantic comedy it would be
the girl is dating another guy it doesn't have to
be death literally but it's the death of that so
now our protagonist learns something about himself
that was in his blind spot that he didn't know
before which now enables him to be to use that
as a tool to change that's why character arcs and
development are so important become a different
person and that enables him to achieve the goal
that he hadn't been able to achieve before nowhere
in the third act where most of the time he has
to defend where he's where he is challenged by
the antagonistic force that he's been battling
throughout the second act one last time and that's
where the big dragon or sauron or whatever rears
his head for the first time attacks him and he has
to prove that the change that he just went through
is a permanent one that can be challenged
and he will still survive with his old ego
end of story so that would be at least the that
is the mythology the thousands of years old
paradigm that stories are building you can go away
from that paradigm as much as you want but I think
it helps to know that that is what audiences
intuitively are expecting and someone who does
that really great is tarantino like I don't think
there's anyone who knows this story structure
better and messes with it and messes with your
expectation which is great but it's different
from not knowing it and just writing something
into the blue and then wondering why people don't
identify with the characters or aren't hooked
to a certain development or something like that
so that would be my my formula structure that I
kind of if I'm if I'm reading it and I'm engrossed
then it doesn't matter if it's a three-act
structure or whatever but if I feel like
my attention kind of drifts and I don't
really care most of the time the answer is
in that structure that somehow doesn't
deliver what it needs to deliver
one of the single most important aspects
of screenwriting any long-form narrative
in novel writing to it just screenwriting in
particular is change things thus everything
in the story must keep changing as it flows it
got it it has to be different five ten minutes
from now than than what the circumstances were
previously 10 minutes ago it has to keep changing
and I came to believe there had to be a pattern
of change and what I discovered was this
this gets a little numeric stick with me
for this uh because it's it's important
and I think enormously useful three acts
okay in a screenplay you've got three acts
first act in act one I noticed there
are six sequences following one another
that I called I came to call hero goal sequences
here's the definition for a hero goal sequence
a hero goal sequence is any two to seven page
section of your screenplay in which and through
which your hero or heroine pursues one short-term
goal physical short-term goal only one as
one step toward achieving the overall story
goal right just just that little piece of it
and at the end of that seven or so nothing is
exact but seven or so pages something happened
or some discovery is made by this hero that
I call fresh news in other words they turn up
something that was unknown by them and by
us by the audience about what they are doing
that puts an end to that current single goal
and offers up a new short term physical single
goal to be pursued in the next step and that
there are six of these hero goal sequences six
little individual pursuits of individual specific
goals in the entirety of act one and what we call
there's many names for this plot point one there's
the the the first major turning point that kind
of thing I call it stunning surprise one when
stunning surprise one happens which ends act
one officially and dramatically ends act one and
kicks the hero forward tumbling head over heel
into act two I call it stunning surprise one
because that should be I believe the emotional
impact on both the hero and the audience it needs
to be emotional and it needs to be impactful
not abstract that always happens in hebrew
goal sequence six always and it continues
in the first half of the second act
there are six more hero goal sequences
and hero goal sequence number 12
always contains the midpoint sequence
that's a separate discussion the midpoint is a
fascinating part of movies that work and it's it's
it's rich and layered with things that go on
relative to character growth and relative to
the plot being bumped up to the next level
and all but it always happens in number 12.
in the second half of act two there are six more
wonder of wonders there are six more hero goal
sequences and hero goal sequence 18 always
contains stunning surprise too not 17 not 19
18 in every movie that works for audiences in
ev in other words every hit movie that you can
analyze because it's doing something right this
is the pattern and then in act 3 it's the only
act where it can vary where the numbers can vary
and in act 3 you have between two and five hero
gold sequences I don't recommend five five it's
good movies have been made with five like uh
as good as it gets which has to be one of my
favorite romantic comedies kind of it has five
hero goal sequences in in in rather extended act
three but the audience is getting antsy and it's
time to get out by then I the standard the average
of movies that work is 21 21 hero goal sequences
18 for acts one and two and
then another three in act three
this is a way I know it sounds kind of weird and
mathematical at this point but this is a way of
quantifying change it tells you in advance
this must happen in these few pages there
it also goes beyond that I mean people were
asking you well and what specifically happens
in each one of these can you nail that down in
a general way yeah I do that in the book I say
well these things usually happen
in hero goal sequence number four
that kind of stuff but that's up for grabs enough
for people to play with but structurally the bones
are these 20 to 23 hero goal sequences laid
out in this exact way and they don't change
it's a three-step process called sequence
proposition plot that was invented by william
thompson price the first step sequence is reverse
cause and effect it's the sequence of cause and
effect that constitute the spine of the story
the forward progression of the story so that
using reverse cause and effect you have to have
the mechanics of the story sketched out first you
can't do plot construction until you have a story
reasonably well figured out with reverse cause and
effect you start at the ending and work backwards
so that you are you're looking at the ending and
you're chaining back from each effect to its
cause so you look at the ending and say okay
well what would be the immediate cause of that
ending and you find the cause of that and then
you say okay what would be the immediate cause of
that and the cause of that and so on and so that
say it's a
it's a um
say it's a story about a someone who's
being muscled by a mafia don no someone
who's being muscled by a corrupt cop and the
corrupt cop puts him in a good strong dilemma
and there's no way out and it gets worse and
worse and worse and this character finally
figures a way out and that he makes a deal with
a mafia don to set up this corrupt cop because
the mafia don wants to take out this corrupt cop
so the character sets a trap so that the crooked
cop shows up to like rob him at the at the key
point and the mafiadon swoops in and takes him out
so the ending would be that the guy is free
from the trap he was caught in before you'd
say well what would cause him to be free it's
that the mafia don snatches the crooked cop and
disappears him the cause of that would be that
the crooked cop swoops in to steal the loot the
cause of that is that he sets up the heist the
fake heist to lure the crooked cop in the cause
of that is that he makes the deal with the mafia
dawn so when you play that and that's all right
dense part of the ending but you could
see the cause and effect there where
he makes the deal with the corrupt mafia
dom which causes him to be able to set up
the crooked heist which causes him to have the the
loot which causes the crooked cop to swoop in and
take it which causes the mafiodon to be able to
grab the cop and disappear which caused them to
walk out of the trap that he
was in so it's it's a way of
of not only stitching together the the story
components by cause and effect but actually um
creating that cause and effect where it may
not exist in other words if you have your story
roughed out and you start doing reverse cause and
effect and you start chaining backwards through
from each effect back to its cause you may get
to a point where there isn't a cause in what
you've figured out so far and that may be a hole
in your plot in the logic of the plot and you say
well what would cause that to happen and you may
come up with a bunch of different possibilities
find the one that works and so then you have the
next cause and then what's the cause of that so
not only are you knitting it together as you build
backwards you're taking what you've already got
a story that's that you've sketched out
but you're now it's like it's like the
when when you've designed a project and
exactly what you want it to do then you
bring in the engineer and say okay make all
the nuts and bolts of this actually work
here's exactly what we want but you got to do
the engineering so we know how heavy the steel
has to be how much concrete to pour and they'll
give you hard numbers of like you need this much
concrete and this much steel so there's one thing
of what you want to achieve there's another of the
engineer comes in and makes it all tells you what
to do to make it all work it's that kind of thing
that as you take the story you've roughed out and
stitch it together engineer it that you actually
create the cause and effect as you build
and the trick to that tool is that you are
asking at each point only what is the cause
of that effect rather than what happens
before it because any number of things can happen
before it but only one thing actually caused it
so that's a way to help separate the necessary
from the unnecessary you're creating a chain
as you work backwards and when you create the
chain for the overall story the chain of events
and you've rigorously included only that which
is necessary to the forward action of the story
and you've rigorously excluded that which is
unnecessary to the forward progression of events
that constitute the spine of your story then
you've assembled it backwards out of your
what the material you have and when you find
holes in your plot you invent to fill them in
so you're not only structuring it but you're
also developing it you're creating when needed
then when you read it from the bottom up a causes
b which causes c which causes d and so on that's
the spine of your story whereas before you had a
lot of clever elements to a story and it looked
like it worked but you hadn't done the engineering
on it to make sure it really worked and
being able to stand back and look at your story
like it starts here and it moves all through here
it also enables you to get a good objective look
at what you've created so far the second step
comes from price's proposition that we were
talking about before using logic to pull
all the story elements together into a coherent
hole like we were talking about how pulp fiction
has three different stories in it but tarantino
did an excellent job of pulling those all together
into a coherent hole it's not a mess of different
stuff it's one thing that happens to be done
in an unusual way but it's still perfectly crafted
from a dramatic point of view it's it's extremely
effective dramatically and great storytelling has
got both so once you've got this tight chain of
events then you set up a set up a conflict set
up a potential conflict early on in the story
touch off a fight to the finish later in the
story and what price said is instead of doing
a and b therefore c he said central to our job as
a dramatist is to have the audience up on the edge
of their seat at the point when the fight to the
finish has only just started and they don't know
how it's going to turn out so at the point when
the fight to the finish has only just started
the audience comes up on the edge of their
seat like how's this going to turn out
because we've got a powerful proactive protagonist
and we've got a powerful proactive antagonist
and we genuinely don't genuinely don't know
who's going to win how it's going to turn out
and so you set it up you touch
it off you get the audience on
the edge of their seat and you've
either got the audience or you don't
in terms of dramatic power on a scale of 1 to
10 how much are they on the edge of their seat
if it's really powerful then you're going wow yes
this I set it up I touched it off and I really
got the audience if you set it up you touch it
off and you can see it's still kind of weak or
it's actually quite weak that's the power that's
what the proposition is for so you can propose it
take an objective look at it and then
evaluate it and then revise as needed
if it's only like a seven out of ten and you're
like no it needs to be I need a nine or a ten
in terms of a scale of one to ten for how
powerfully I have the audience on the edge
of their seat at this point when the when what
the whole story is built up to is unresolved
then you amplify different aspects of it to get
the audience that much more on the edge of rc
so you're you're creating a tight sequence
of cause and effect then looking at the core
conflict in the story because it's really just
two boxers in a ring fighting it out it's two
dogs fighting over a bone only one of them is
going to walk away in the end in fact the oldest
greek drama was only two characters on stage the
introduction of the third character by sophocles
was considered a major innovation in drama so
the ability to see the core of your plot as two
main fighters in a fight to the finish
and only one of them is going to walk away
helps you get right at the core of what makes
your story work dramatically the last step is
the answering of the riddle the completion of the
action what how the fight to the finish shakes out
in the back and forth between protag and his
antagonist and who wins or loses in the end so
reverse cause and effect set up the fight touch
it off get the audience on the edge of their seat
and wrap it up so that's sequence proposition plot
some writing teachers say the three act
structure is dead it's it's it's remedial
it's it it's it's not going to it's it's going
to kill any creativity and the problem with that
is that they don't understand what the three-act
structure is because the three-act structure is
has nothing to do with plotting in
my opinion and unfortunately the a
lot of story structure is taught by story
analysts who are brilliant left-brained
brainers and are really adept at deconstructing
a masterpiece and and the implication is that now
that we've deconstructed this you
should go off and write your masterpiece
and while there's tremendous amount of value
in in in studying film theory or or or or
film theory because it's that that's that's
deconstructing casablanca or citizen kane
is is going to help you understand uh how a story
was built to some degree but it's not going to
teach you process it's not going to teach you
how to organize your ideas when you look at a
movie like casablanca and you think about the
epstein brothers writing we're structuring this
this movie they I'm interested in in the process
I'm interested in how did somebody come to write
this in other words you can you can like just
because you deconstruct something it's like
vivisection you can't you can't take something
dead and look at all of its existing parts and
then and then reanimate it it's not going to
come back to life and so just because you can
break down this thing into its its separate parts
doesn't mean you're going to uncover the mystery
of what the thing actually is in other words story
structure is really the dna of your protagonist's
transformation that makes sense story shows
the dna of a protagonist transformation
it's not in the midpoint there should be a
a reversal like I don't even know what that
means you hear it all the time with with uh
these story analysts that should be reversible
what the hell does does does it's a wonderful life
have a a reversal that's where mr potter offers
jimmy stewart a job and jimmy stewart says no I
don't know I don't I think of I think of story
structure as not a conceptual model something
you can figure out but it's it's more of a
experiential model in other words your
protagonist goes through a series of experiences
that lead to a transformation and I think of story
structure as an immutable paradigm for a spiritual
transformation okay it's immutable it never
changes but that doesn't make it that doesn't
that doesn't limit your creativity that actually
paradoxically opens your creativity in other words
when when you really understand what story
structure is it moves you beyond your limited
imagination of what your story is I always
tell my writers your idea of your story is
not the whole story it's not that it's incorrect
it's that it's incomplete and so if you were to
distill story structure to three words it
would be desire surrender transformation
so show me any story there's you're going
to have a character that wants something
desire you're going to have a character that lets
go of the meaning they made out of their goal
surrender you're going to have a character that
experiences transformation in other words a
shift in perception a reframing of their
relationship to their goal show me a story
that doesn't have that and I'll show you a story
that doesn't work or is really experimental
everything was in a four-act structure
on television because it had to allow
for advertising every 13 minutes or
so so you would divide your 60 minutes
into roughly four acts roughly four 15-minute
segments they weren't really exactly 15 minutes
but something like that so that there could
be a commercial break at the end of each one
and then there was a teaser generally this
traditional traditional structure which I'll
tell you was the show's title with even a theme
song then sometimes there was a small commercial
even right away and then there's the teaser
anywhere from 30 seconds to five minutes which
literally teases the action or sometimes in a
procedural would give you the crime or the case
to be solved then there'd be a commercial then
you'd go into act one which would go to roughly
20 minutes 18 20 pages then there'd be a
commercial act 2 would go to roughly 30 ish pages
this is traditional act break act three
which is the worst case the climactic
encounter would go to roughly page 45-ish and then
act four would go to the end and would be slightly
shorter would probably be 57 58 or 55 minutes and
then there'd be another act break and and another
commercial then it got longer and in 2006 abc
decided that they wanted to go to six acts
in order to stick stick in more commercials
and so you ended up with a very long act one
so the people wouldn't lose you and then they
break act six into act four into four and
five and then there would be a tag after the
final act which sometimes led into the next week
and they would get more commercials in and this
just got worse and worse and worse and worse
where there were some shows on traditional
networks that had almost more commercial
material than dramatic material in terms of
structure after you get to your final act
in some shows not all of them there's a form
where there's an act break or a break of some sort
and then there's more dramatic material and that
extra dramatic material is usually quite short it
might be one scene or two scenes maybe three
scenes but not really much longer and either
it does something as a commentary on what that
episode was about and twists it or it just simply
starts introducing what's going to be on the
next episode every show is different you don't
find this thing very much on on streaming
and so this we're really when we talk about
act breaks and the four or five or six acts or
the number of acts plus the teaser and a tag
we're really we're really dealing with traditional
legacy television I found that even after
the traditional forex structure was abandoned
by networks that as I talked to people who are
writing for netflix or hbo or any other form
at all amazon when I talked to seasoned writers
they were all still using it and just dropping
out the act break and the reason they were using
it is that it works it works as a storytelling
mechanism even if it does not need to be something
that accommodates advertising and that was very
interesting that given the option to not use it
plenty of people figured out gee I need a form
anyway and you don't just start on page one
and go to page 60 or whatever in a row without
having any idea where the where the changes are
where the emphasis are where the energy goes
this way or that way what about cliffhangers
and it was discovered by a number of of seasoned
writers that what I can go back to the tools that
I always used without ever having calling it a
break or having an ad and what it has to do with
the rhythm of experience that there is a something
but I think there may be something biological
in the roughly 15-minute span if you go to a movie
a movie in a theater of which there aren't very
many anymore but if you were to go in a movie in
a successful movie in a theater and you observe
you'd know you might notice that roughly every 13
or 15 minutes a little around the audience squirms
and I've observed this several times and I think
it is actually biological I think people are
looking for a change of pace they're looking for
a cliffhanger they're looking for something that
turns the action in another direction in what
some people have called a plot point though you
don't need to use that terminology and I think
there is something to rid the rhythm of writing
in fact if you look at the traditional three-act
structure this the old sid feels 3x structure
which wasn't invented by sid fields it predates
him by a long time but anyway that structure
said that act act one was one quarter of the
time act two is two quarters of the time half
and act three is one quarter of the time and
that's how the three acts work they're not three
even acts the second act is double but if you draw
a median line down the middle of that second act
which is often where the mid story character comes
in and chan where there's a big change you're back
you've got four acts and so you're still back to
the same thing now it plays out differently in a
hundred minutes than it would in 60 minutes but
not that differently and so people experiment
with what netflix will tell you and what hbo will
tell you is don't talk to me about act breaks
write what the story needs write it whatever
length the story needs to be and we'll deal with
it and I think that's wonderful as a very generous
way of approaching writers the writer still has
to go home and structure the story so what the
story needs to be still needs turns still needs
anticipation still needs what used to be called
plot points still needs a motor that drives to
certain kinds of flips and and still needs some
resolution so you find yourself back with some of
the most traditional lessons in how to write as
you write for even the most advanced television
when you're staffed right you're writing to
whatever the network or the streaming service does
there's there's a variety of different structures
that that brings about for instance most of
the abc dramas that I know of I will not say all
about any of them are written in six act structure
so what 6x structure means is that you're
you're basically everything's kind of a little
symmetrical right you've got this many pages here
this many pages in each act building to those act
out through those commercial breaks and because
it's so act out driven it really changes the
pacing of the show if you wat most abc shows will
feel like they move very quickly and it's because
of that symmetrical nature of the axe shows on cbs
are often teaser four is the structure it's also
often called five act structure it just depends
on who's referring to it but what it does is allow
you to write a longer teaser that can sometimes be
more luxurious and get more of your story set up
and then you you use the following
forex to complete your storytelling
shows that I will say I think have done that
are like the good wife right would sometimes
have those really long opening setups before the
title card so that's your long luxurious teaser
and then the rest of the show is the five-act
structure so those that's the main stuff six act
teaser four or five act five act tends to have
a shorter teaser that then the basically starts
act one so it's like short teaser title
card rest of act one as opposed to being
a separate entity like teaser four is so those
are the varying different things and you can
again if you can get a hold of scripts for
different shows you can research how they did it
in streaming shows when you read our scripts there
there won't be any act designations because there
are typically no commercial breaks although now
that netflix is going to have an ad tier I don't
know if that's going to change or they're going
to ask us to tell them where the commercial
breaks are like we do in broadcast tbd but
again to something I spoke about earlier and
that I think is really important breaking
the story as if those act breaks exist
will help with your storytelling and help with the
emotional ebb and flow of the episode so that it
doesn't feel like you're waiting till the end of
the show to do all the really important things
because I think what happens is people are like
well we can have all these nice long conversations
or we can have this great big huge set piece
but then you're not really getting a lot of
variation in the episode it's just like talk talk
talk talk talk everything happens or it's like
talking talking huge set piece talking talking
talking talking talking boom ending and that's
like a it's not really a great pleasurable
experience when you watch tv you want to like
be drawn in and then like okay I can rest a little
bit so that that act break structure even if you
take act breaks out of your script is a really
good way to do it in most shows you will have your
a story is the main story of the episode it is
the driving story usually of your main characters
not always true but often true and so say for
instance and I'll use swat as an example because
we very clearly wrote a b and c stories so your
a story is the crime of the week right what who
are the bad guys we're challenging what have they
done what are we trying to stop them from doing
and you will develop that whole story and who in
our cast is that story really affecting right now
eight out of ten episodes that's going to be
hondo but sometimes it's a personal case from
the past for one of our other characters or if
someone's friend was injured in the crime and so
they're the ones who are emotionally affected
by what we're doing so that's your a story
your b story and your c story are the supporting
stories in the episode and they are usually more
character focused so it's a chance for your
second tier characters to get moments right
so say again in an episode of swat a b story might
be street and chris have like admitted that they
like each other but they're still like oh can
we date no we can't date what are we going to
do about this mess so that romantic intrigue is
your b story sometimes it also will cross into
your a story right because it's like they're on
a call together and they've just had this fight
about the fact that they can't date each other
but then like something dangerous happens and
then it's so clear that much they love each other
right so it's like you're building that stuff into
the a story but you're breaking their arc on
its own and then a c story is usually a runner
right it's like a three four beat story that
sometimes adds some humor to the episode
sometimes it's to tie off a loose end that we've
left floating from a prior episode of like did
that couple break up we don't know and so we'll
do like three beats where we finally reveal like
did the couple break up oh no no they're still
together look at that surprise like whatever it is
sometimes it's a way to give an actor who
has maybe not been as focused on in the show
a chance to shine so you're giving them
three or four scenes that are really about
them and their character and letting them
like hey I'm here pay attention to me so
that's really what those things break down to it's
your main story your secondary story and then c
story is usually a runner you will sometimes like
in a finale episode your b and c stories will feel
about equal because finales are all about wrapping
up the emotional arcs of the entire season so
sometimes it's like you've got three relationship
stories going and you have to get somewhere with
all of them so you'll you suss that out in the
moment but that's in general how that works
because short films can do anything
or say anything and they should be
unexpected and you can do act you're ending at the
beginning and you're beginning at the end there is
no structure so but I do think simplicity helps
a lot I don't think you should have a hundred
different characters with a hundred different
plots going on and a b lines it's not like
screenwriting that's when people take do a short
film screenwriting I'm always kind of like what
could you be talking about because there aren't
the same kind of rules as there are for features
it really depends on what story you want to
tell and then I just think it's a lot about
simplification and really bringing it down to a
simple idea and one thing I love about short films
because I'm known for short films right people
will always say to me oh I saw this really great
short film and then they'll tell me the short
film that they saw so I haven't visually seen
it but I've heard someone tell me to and I'll be
like that sounds like a great short film and I
kind of feel like I've seen it because they were
able to tell me the whole plot of what it was so
your short story your short film should work
in that way that people can tell you what it is
but a lot of them are like just visual one of my
favorite kinds of short films are dialogue free
short films where there's absolutely no dialogue
but it is all told it's not like an old-fashioned
running pushing piano up the hill and having
a fall down laurel and hardy kind of thing
but just you can tell a story with visuals the
actual old-fashioned visual filmmaking way and
it's great and so many and those I'll also say the
short films with no dialogue translate very well
translate very well for different countries people
love films with no dialogue because it's universal
it's going to be a universal story of something
that is told through cinema it's a very cinematic
way of telling a story but anyway so yeah nothing
you can do anything you want to do and I could try
to talk you out of like don't do like traditional
structure but you can do traditional structure if
that's what your story needs and is to be told
endings are really important in short films
beginnings are really important to short films
and middles are very important in short films
I do think every scene in your short film
should also you've got to look at it and say
beginning and ending are we lingering too long
can we get out and do that before you shoot it
because again every moment counts and if you're
going to have a longer shoot if you have a bunch
of stuff in it that later you're going to cut out
in editing evaluate every scene look at the does
it start as late as it can does it end as early
as it possibly can and then do you really need it
what is the scene actually about and have we
already done that I hate short films where it just
takes forever to get to the storyline or they they
have a big opening credit sequence of somebody
driving in a car with beautiful scenery going
on and the credits say costumes buy and dp buy
and it's like no for feature films contractually
you have to do that they have to have full screen
credits for short film there's nothing like
that we have no opening credit sequence people
don't want to sit through that we don't want to
see that start right away with what your story is
and you don't everything should be what needs to
be nothing superfluous nothing that is just there
because it may entertains you you can have a super
chatty film too but just make sure everything
that's in there and chatty needs to be in there
so so I say probably the biggest thing about the
structure is just make sure it starts good make
sure it ends good make sure everything in there
needs to be in there has to be in there and as
tight as possible and that you're happy with it.